Maybe there is hope for these functions, though. Perhaps some domain
restrictions could help us out. After all, if we only look at part of these
graphs, it might be that the part we leave passes the horizontal line test.
That will mean that, that part at least, would have an inverse. Let's just
focus in on one of these two for the moment. If we look at this function, only
in the part of the domain where x is greater than or equal to 0, does that
function have an inverse? And then secondly, if we look at the function only
where x is less than or equal to 0, does that function have an inverse? Think
about which parts of this graph each of these are looking at, and then decide
whether or not they each pass the horizontal line test.